Joe's here because he's been writing
himself more and more into the program
Peggy Pete we actually recently did a
bit on the show here where we talked
about how much we love the product I
can't believe it's not butter yeah we
love it because the name of the product
sounds like a snippet of an actual
conversation about the product yes and
we had a lot of fun giving our own
suggestions for new products whose names
could continue that conversation take a
look we did this on a past episode come
on bro
if this isn't butter just level with me
right now before I go to work I can't be
thinking about this all day online and
some fans of the show are actually kind
enough to tweet us some butter
substitute products that are actually
real even though they sound totally fake
none of these are made up at te Hooper
sent us this one you'd think it's butter
as in that yellow spreadable paste
you're eating you'd think it's butter
but boy would you be surprised at that
point they should just call it beat the
out of me
at underscore acute poison sent us this
one on Twitter well I totally thought it
was butter as in this is wood glue Wow I
totally thought it was butter am I gonna
die why did you put wood glue in the
refrigerator I'm a label they even put
butter in closet that should just be
that would be a great name on its own
for a substitute product just butter in
quotes just like right to it
finally at Stephen Bay Shore sent us
this one memories of butter the name of
that product is so poetic it sounds like
the sequel to The Notebook or it being
like a soldier's memoir
during the Second World War no matter
where I was stationed the thing that
kept me sane during those long nights
was the moon's gentle illuminating gaze
and memories of butter
where you so much everyone the Broncos
who are attention and if anyone else box
a good fake one
send them our way stick around